-Well, results from last
night's wild midterm elections
are still rolling in
and several races are still
too close to call,
including control of both
the House and Senate,
so, we have to be patient.
As of right now, our decision
desk here at "Late Night"
is using very cautious language
to describe the state
of the race this way.
"With 87%
of precincts reporting,
we can now project the...
[ Laughter ]
I forgot to mention
our election guy is
from New Jersey, like Dr. Oz.
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oh, man!
Where to begin, you guys?
I turned my phone off last night
at 7:00 pm and went to bed.
Didn't even check the results
until I dropped my kids
off at school,
so, I am well-rested
and feeling good.
Now, you might say, "Seth,
you knew you'd have to address
the election today.
How could you just
tune out like that?"
It's easy. I made my staff
pull an all-nighter.
[ Laughter ]
And, it should be noted,
they look like [bleep] today.
[ Laughter ]
Point is, I tuned out because,
as I'm sure you all heard,
going into this election,
pundits,
especially on the right,
but across the media spectrum,
were certain the Democrats
were going to get
absolutely annihilated.
-Fifteen days to the midterms
and there's more and more signs
of a red wave.
-I really believe
it's going to be
a strong red wave
for the Republicans.
-It's going to be
a big red wave.
-Do you think
the red wave is coming?
I mean, like "Winter is coming,"
it's red wave coming?
-You're of the mind-set
it's red wave.
-Absolutely.
-I think that this is going
to be a big red wave.
-It'll be a huge red wave
and it'll be
a big blue wipeout.
-They are very,
very concerned about this,
you know, red riptide,
if not a red wave,
if not a red tsunami.
-I see,
not a red wave.
I see a red tsunami.
-We're not just going
to see a red wave.
We're going
to see a red tsunami.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, that last one was a bit
of a giveaway
because, if there was truly
a tsunami coming,
we all know Ted Cruz
would've been
on the first flight to Cancun.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Cruz ]
Red waves are great,
but I prefer the blue waves
outside the Cancun Ritz Carlton.
[ Laughter ]
I'll bring you back
a conk fritter.
Stay warm, everybody.
Also, I did appreciate
the "Game of Thrones" reference.
-Do you think
the red wave is coming?
I mean, like "Winter is coming,"
it's red wave coming?
[ Laughter ]
-I would say it was less like
a red wave
and more like a Red Wedding.
[ Laughter ]
-The Republicans were the Starks
and Donald Trump was a dragon
who burned his whole
[bleep] party to a crisp.
[ Laughter ]
And don't just take
my word for it.
Listen to Republicans
and right-wing pundits
themselves,
who spent the last 24 hours
wringing their hands,
wondering where it
all went wrong.
-I thought the political
conditions were such
that would suggest a red wave.
The polling said otherwise
and I was skeptical
of the polling.
The polling's held up
pretty well tonight.
-The big red wave
that was predicted
has not happened yet.
-There wasn't
a red wave.
[ Laughter ]
That is a searing indictment
of the Republican Party.
of the message
that we have been sending
to the voters.
The Republican Party needs to do
a really deep introspection,
look in the mirror right now
because this is
an absolute disaster.
-Definitely not
a Republican wave,
that's for darn sure.
-[ As Graham ]
This is definitely not
a Republican wave.
It was more like
the wave my Meemaw makes
when she jumps
in the bathtub with me.
[ Laughter ]
She barely moves the water
because she's about 84 pounds
soaking wet.
Meemaw, I'm a grown man!
[ Laughter ]
I don't take baths
with you anymore, Meemaw!
[ Laughter ]
Now, on one hand,
there's still much
to be decided.
Control of both houses
of Congress
is, essentially,
a toss-up right now
and Republicans could still
end up winning
both the House and the Senate,
so, it's wise to be cautious.
But on the other hand, despite
strong political head winds,
including the fact
that, historically,
the party in power tends
to get swamped in the midterms,
the race for both
the House and Senate
is, essentially,
a toss-up as of this taping,
which is crazy.
Democrats actually flipped
some long-held
Republican House seats
in states like Ohio,
while also winning back
governorships
in states like Maryland
and Massachusetts;
Americans voted
to protect abortion rights
in several states,
through ballot initiatives,
including in Kentucky;
expanded Medicaid
in South Dakota;
guaranteed a right to unionize
in Illinois;
and legalized marijuana
in Missouri.
At this point,
I wouldn't be shocked
if we found out voters in Kansas
passed a ballot initiative to...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Which they should, because that
would be fun as hell!
[ Laughter ]
By far, the most dramatic,
and my favorite, example
of how poorly things went
for Republicans last night
is a shocking development
in Colorado's
3rd Congressional District,
where Lauren Boebert is,
as of this taping,
trailing her
Democratic opponent
in a race absolutely no one
thought would be competitive.
-In Colorado, a hardline
pro-Trump Republican
on the ropes.
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert
behind by a few thousand votes
right now.
-This is Lauren Boebert's
seat here.
Not even a seat
that we considered
to be competitive,
leading into Election Day.
Lauren Boebert is trailing
by about 3,500 votes.
Lauren Boebert is
an election denying,
very conservative Republican.
Democrats would love
to unseat her.
I'm not sure they thought
they had a chance to.
They have a chance.
-I'm not saying I was excited
last night
when I saw those results,
but I did rush
into my kids' room at 3:00 am
to shake them and scream,
"Wake up!
Lauren Boebert is losing!"
[ Laughter ]
And they know who she is
because I tell them, if they
don't eat their vegetables,
they'll get a visit from...
[ Laughter and applause ]
By the way, if you're
confusing her with Sarah Palin,
who's also running for Congress
this year in Alaska,
don't worry --
they're both losing,
so you don't even need
to give them straight.
[ Laughter ]
By far, the biggest prize
of the night was
in Pennsylvania,
where both the governorship
and the Senate seat,
which is held
by a retiring Republican,
were seen as two of the most
closely watched races
when election season began.
Democratic candidate
for governor Josh Shapiro
ran away with it and crushed
his pro-Trump election denier
opponent, Doug Mastriano.
But the even bigger victory
for Democrats,
and, possibly, the biggest
disappointment in the night
for Republicans,
was the Senate race.
-Fox News can project
that Lieutenant Governor
John Fetterman
will win the Pennsylvania Senate
race over Dr. Mehmet Oz.
This is a huge win
for the Democrats.
-Wow!
I can't believe a candidate
with no government experience,
who lives in New Jersey
and reportedly killed
over 300 dogs
[ Laughter ]
lost a race for Senate
in Pennsylvania.
[ Laughter ]
The only way Oz could've been
a worse candidate
in Pennsylvania was
if he was seen
in a Devils jersey,
fighting with Gritty,
screaming,
"7-Eleven is better
than Wawa and Sheetz."
[ Laughter ]
Oz's closing argument included,
among other things,
posting an incredibly bizarre
photo of himself
[ Laughter ]
standing under a sign
displaying gas prices
on the side of the road,
like he was looking to sell some
of his off-brand diet pills
and urging people,
this past Saturday,
"to contact 10
other potential supporters,"
saying, "Do it
before the Steelers game,"
despite the fact that there was
no Steelers game on Sunday.
[ Laughter ]
The team had a bye week
and any Pittsburgher worth their
salt would tell you
that not knowing the Steelers
had a bye week
[ Changes accent ]
is a total jagoff move.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm being hard on him.
I do think Oz knows
Pittsburgh well,
based on this clip he put out,
where he, very naturally,
mentioned what the city
is known for.
-I love,
love being in Pittsburgh.
Now, people think I come here
for the food,
and I do like beer
and sandwiches,
but it's the food
for thought
that I really came
to Pittsburgh for.
-Okay, Russian
spy from the '50s.
[ Laughter ]
[ Slavic accent ]
Hello, local barkeep.
I'm here for a beer,
and sandwiches.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, is true there is
nuke-ular power plant in town?
[ Laughter ]
How would curious visitor
take tour to see up close?
[ Laughter ]
Part of the reason Fetterman's
win was such a big deal was
because many
in the Republican bubble
clearly thought
it was impossible.
Some right-wing pundits
straight-up said, in advance,
there was no way it could happen
and that it would be ridiculous
to wake up on Wednesday
to a Fetterman victory.
-It's not about the person.
It's about the party.
It's not about the individual.
It's about the group.
And, to prove it,
they can even run
mentally defective candidates
who can barely speak
and not only expect them
to [ Raising voice ] "win,"
but expect you to accept
the outcome,
no matter how transparently
absurd it is.
On November 9th,
they'll be telling you
that John Fetterman got
81 million votes in Pennsylvania
and they'll threaten
to put you in jail,
if you don't believe it.
Why wouldn't they do that?
It worked with Joe Biden.
-[ As Carlson ]
Why wouldn't they do that?
Why wouldn't they tell you
John Fetterman won
and threaten to put you in jail,
if you don't believe it?
When you're in jail,
why wouldn't they put you
on laundry duty?
And, when you tell them
you've never done
your own laundry before
and don't know how it works,
why wouldn't the other inmates
laugh at you?
And when you tell them
to stop laughing,
because it's not funny,
why wouldn't they put you
[ Laughter ]
in the dryer, where you would
get tossed around --
with a load of their underpants,
I should add -- for 45 minutes?
Why wouldn't they do that?
[ Laughter ]
Because they did it to me.
In high school.
[ Laughter ]
And again in college.
I bet, when Tucker
woke up this morning
and saw the results,
he made that face
he always makes,
like he buzzed in on "Jeopardy!"
and forgot what
he was going to say.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And yet, Fetterman
very much did win,
as Tucker's own network
explained this morning.
-When it comes to the state
of Pennsylvania,
why did Dr. Oz lose?
Well, it looks like,
according to the exit polling,
it's because Fetterman won!
-Yeah!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
That is,
historically, how it works.
[ Laughter ]
When one candidate loses,
the other wins.
Although, in fairness,
there are probably Republicans
who need that explained to them.
[ As Walker ]
Whoa! If Warnock loses, I win?
Ohhhhh, that is not a good idea.
Now, again, there are many races
that have yet to be called
and, still, a wide range
of possibility.
Current projections,
as of this taping,
range anywhere from Democrats
holding both the House
and Senate
to razor-thin majorities
for Republicans.
But, from what we already know,
this election went much better
than Joe Biden could've
possibly expected,
given the stiff political
head winds he was facing
and history,
because incumbent parties
almost always lose tons
of seats in the midterms.
And, yet, Biden managed
to outperform
those expectations, despite
constant second-guessing,
even from his fellow
Democrats, about his strategy.
-It's a better night than
expected for the Democrats.
You know, what are you hearing
from the White House?
-A big change of mood
from the White House
in the past 24 hours.
They feel excitement,
mixed with some validation,
because they managed,
they think,
to buck a historic trend --
they didn't lose dozens
of seats,
the way previous
presidents have.
-So, the lesson is
don't bet against Joe Biden.
-Don't bet against Biden.
-Politically,
the guy always finds a way,
it seems.
-That's right --
whatever you think of him,
never bet against an old man
who's spent more time
in Scranton dive bars
than most people have
at their actual jobs.
[ Laughter ]
Joe Biden is
the Mike Ehrmantraut
of American politics.
[ Laughter ]
You think you can jump him
on a dark street
and take his wallet
and, the next thing you know,
you're rolling on the ground,
yelling,
"My arm! You broke my arm!"
[ Laughter ]
[ As Mike ]
Here's what we're going
to do now.
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
Finally, finally, found it,
right at the last minute.
[ Laughter ]
You know, we have a tendency
to think of Biden
as a doddering old man
because, you know, he's an old
man who sometimes dotters,
[ Laughter ]
but after last night's results,
I'm starting to think
he might actually be
the greatest political
mastermind of our generation.
Maybe the whole Mr. Magoo thing
is a put-on.
You know how he's always putting
his head in his hands
while answering questions
or getting stuck onstage
like a motion center Santa Claus
[ Laughter ]
that runs out of batteries.
Maybe it's all an act
to disguise the fact
that he's actually
a Machiavellian genius
who's constantly doing
electoral math in his head.
While the rest of us
are having fun,
laughing at his gaffes,
he's sitting there, saying --
[ As Biden ]
Laugh it up, mother[bleep]!
[ Laughter ]
I'm about to have
the best midterm result
for a sitting president
in two decades.
Biden's performance last night
was certainly
much better than Donald Trump's,
who's getting all the blame
from his party
for backing a bunch of weirdos,
clowns, and bozos
[ Laughter ]
who got creamed in their races.
Last night was, if nothing else,
clearly a strong repudiation
of Trumpism from voters
and that's according
to almost everyone,
except, of course --
brace yourselves --
Trump himself.
[ Laughter ]
-You've endorsed more
than 330 candidates
this election cycle.
Tonight, win or lose,
the results for Republicans,
how much of that will be
because of Donald Trump?
-Well, I think, if they win,
I should get all the credit;
[ Laughter ]
and, if they lose,
I should not be blamed
at all, okay?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I don't think
that's how it works,
although I'm sure it's not
the first time he's tried.
[ As Trump ]
I want to bet $100 on the Jets,
but here's the thing --
if they win, you pay me.
If they lose,
I get my money back.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, of course,
that's what Trump would say.
That's how he's operated
his whole life.
He wants credit for everything
and blame for nothing.
He's the definition
of a "Heads, I win;
tails, you lose" kind of guy,
except, he still
somehow manages to lose.
[ As Trump ]
Heads, I win; tails, you lose.
And now let's flip the coin.
And it has been snatched
out of the air by the IRS.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I owe them $1 billion
in back taxes
and they're taking it
one quarter at a time.
[ Laughter ]
So, Democrats won a bunch
of key races last night,
despite dire predictions
of a red wave that fizzled out.
Now, control of both the House
and the Senate is,
as of this taping,
still up for grabs,
which is, in itself,
a wild outcome
and a huge disaster
for Republicans,
among many other things.
We learned last night
that people are just tired
of Donald Trump's clown car
of bozos and dip[bleep].
They want to protect democracy.
They want to protect
reproductive rights.
They want competent governance
and they want to vote
for candidates in one election
who aren't going to ignore
their votes in the next one.
They just want to go
about their lives
like ordinary Americans
and enjoy their...
-Beer and sandwiches.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪